hello guys I'm Ryan right
I'm Lisa metallic Lisa mihalick is here
with me today I have introduced her to
Ronald McDonald in Iraq Iraq a channel
I shudder I showed her the chicken store
Massacre video to prepare her for Ronald
McDonald WWE beatdown and am I prepared
I don't know I heard this is like live
or something some live event I I'm not
sure what it is it might be Ronald
McDonald at WWE okay well you look
really nervous I'm scared I'm scared of
clowns in general in the fact that this
is like violent - it's yeah I'm kind of
freaked out but hmm
but violence does not sexually excited
yeah trust me it does not haha let's do
this lease of a hellish a it's my Helen
McCulloch hard
oh I missed the beginning you said hard
see that I was thinking hard like don't
say it dude don't say
life can be dangerous
that's right he's gonna [ __ ] him up
discord I think is real I don't mean
sketch
yeah they're really like a live event
yeah that's cool
Oh
Oh
what are those trash man
this is great
or you like right
my college in wrestling
like some taxes
eyes
are you Ronald
Wow
haha oh [ __ ]
ouch
there's must've been really well courier
devices go on it I'm doing it
grandma
no way No
no they're really delivering on the
goods
ouch
are you lost
no one's steering
good for them
i'ma tell you how these you have a piece
of flesh to us oh the real shame you
know oh man to some extremes with it
kudos to those guys ah those were some
stunts hey it's really cool to see the
how these guys are from YouTube we're
able to put this event together and then
make it something where everyone online
could watch it and that was a that was
fun to watch to see a character from
like this Ronald McDonald character go
into wrestling yeah really commit to the
stunts showing that it's more than just
film tricks that they would do right or
than a lot of their violence like know
that this they commit what is my grandma
falling down
that was insane what how do you even how
do you film that
how do you get that to happen I don't
know it looked real yeah I thought you
really happened Rokan half and
everything yeah and I think I mean the
whole thing was real yeah it was just
well choreographed really really well
choreographed it was entertaining I one
thing I wanted was for did get really
bloody I was hoping they would do some
like bloody effects right so were they a
team than the grandma and the grandpa
okay it's hobby ish well I know but they
only choose the grand fund the beginning
and then Ronald only had himself I know
what if you've ever get singing up on
him bringing like a thick back or
something
a big mac it's my favorite restaurant is
it we should get it yes do you like
their breakfast all day and am I so
happy it's all day house shoot breakfast
burritos and a nice coffee I like the
two sausage McMuffin with egg well okay
any anything really I mean I you say
anything and I'll just like melt you'd
be the cheapest date in the world to my
favorite restaurant that's awesome guys
keep an out kudos to Iraq Iraq I just
wanted to introduce Lisa to them
and he off that video you showed me
before though that was that was
disturbing there is worse I was honestly
expecting to be more scared that's why
when he started the video and I was like
nervous like this this is Mike this is
more of a special event for fans of the
channel and the fans of you know the
Ronald McDonald character right it's
cool that they were able to bring an
event to life you know where they all
get to see the character in action well
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe today and come a reject
you can check out Lisa on Instagram
where you can see this lovely face all
over her page and looking at her hair
and her eyes and you feel like you're
falling in love with her do it guys
do it thank you Wow yeah just don't
touch welp
are they allowed to do what never mind